oh you from gardena what you know
about gardena
i know they got type of noodles there
okay i'm from my park
really because i was getting laderra
hats about to me
ladera boy i'm from florence and
crenshaw don't blame me
how can i play somebody who orders
crawfish tail and colin green's like
this isn't a date
oh this is a date maybe i'm too sober to
notice
well i can fix that miley square you
want a doug's passion
are we still talking about the drink or
i am not
so why'd you dodge me for so long
honestly
i was embarrassed by coachella
i was doing the most and you didn't need
to see all that well maybe that's a good
thing
you don't have to pretend with each
other
true well since we're not pretending
i do got to get back to work on a
saturday
okay no but for real i got a lot of work
to do
and i'm trying to redeem myself for this
presentation
but i mean if you free tomorrow maybe we
can
hang out when you bring the passion i'll
bring the thug
come on say it say it out loud it's good
welcome you're saying florence and
crenshaw i got to bring a little thug
leave that to me look at that okay bro
you got baby hair and that's a fact
about you
you